hello
and welcome to solutions for scaling
massive
global games in the cloud i'm rob martin
chief architect for gaming at google
cloud
and i'm sebastian weigan a planet scale
systems architect on rob's team
and today we're going to be talking a
lot about global games
first we're going to define what we mean
by a global game
next we're going to define all of the
components that are used to power
a global game in the cloud then we're
going to do a demo
and finally we'll close out with some
thoughts on a toolkit for building your
own global game
in the cloud so let's start by talking
about global games
gaming is the world's most popular form
of entertainment
with 2.7 billion players globally
and that number is expected to increase
by another
half billion by 2023
let's talk about an example of a truly
global game
apex legends is a great example of a
truly global game
apex legends launched exclusively on gcp
with our partner multiplay within the
first
eight hours after launch over a million
players
had played the game within the first
three days that number 10xed to 10
million players
and by the end of the first month over
50 million players had joined the fun
in apex legends so let's talk
about concurrency and scaling a ccu
is defined as one concurrent player
peak ccu is the maximum number of
players during the day
that will be playing your game all at
one time
you can see many points of peak ccu
illustrated in the diagrams to the right
as players join your game you'll need to
scale up
infrastructure to meet that demand so in
some sense
as more ccus join your game you'll need
to scale up more
cpus in the cloud to power the
multiplayer experiences
let's take a look at a few different
examples of peak ccus
so the first example is a premium launch
where
the game is launched perhaps at retail
there's a very large peak ccu spike on
the first day
and then you settle into a predictable
pattern in the following days
or in the second example you might have
a mobile launch where you have
a limited beta and then over time user
acquisition opens up to add more and
more concurrent players
what we're seeing more and more of today
with today's free to play games like
apex legends that incorporate
content drops seasons and live events
as you're seeing peaks happening
throughout the game's life cycle
so in today's world it's very important
to be able to scale
to these unpredictable demand peaks that
are generated by these
new types of content releases and so
we've talked about concurrency and
scaling
now let's talk about geography so using
an example game with a million
concurrent players
those players are going to be
distributed all around the earth
using this example of a typical aaa pc
console game
we would expect about 40 percent of
those concurrent players to be located
in north america we'd see about 30
percent of those players
in europe about 10 percent in south
america
and then the remaining 20 percent of
players distributed
across the middle east and asia now
because latency
matters in gaming you're going to need
to deploy your compute resources
all around the earth to get them as
close as possible to your players
so as seb and i prepared for this demo
we thought to ourselves
would it be possible to scale up all of
the compute infrastructure
required to run a global game for 1
million concurrent players
within the space of this 25-minute demo
what do you think sam with the right
tools
anything is possible all right rob
let's dive in i've created these
clusters already and i've installed a
gonais onto each of them
right now these are essentially empty
clusters running only a few nodes each
i've got one cluster in the u.s another
in the netherlands
and a third in japan because our cloud
console aggregates information across
clusters
i can see that i don't have anything
running in these clusters yet besides
the pods needed to run agonist itself
i've coded up a game server in go which
simulates a battle royale style game
it records the events which typically
take place into bigquery
our data warehouse it also creates
player information such as match
rankings
and writes those into spanner our
horizontally scalable relational
database
to deploy this server worldwide we
define it using a nagonese game server
fleet spec
combined with a google cloud game
servers deployment fleet specification
looks just like any other kubernetes
resource agonist provides an abstraction
layer on top of kubernetes to understand
the concept of a game server
or collection of game servers called a
fleet
it does this because game servers aren't
your typical stateless workload
you don't want your game to get killed
in the middle of a match and scheduled
on another note
for example likewise kubernetes needs to
know more information about the state
that the game server is in
such as total player count to handle
functions like scaling properly
agonist takes care of things like this
for us so that we don't have to
let's take a look at our current fleets
on each of the gke clusters
as you can see we don't have any fleets
deployed
let's go ahead and create a ton of game
servers
to do this i'm going to ask gcgs to
apply a new rollout
using the configs i've specified what
it'll do
is connect to every gke cluster in each
of the realms
and create the agonised fleets based
upon our fleet spec
in short we'll go from no pods to
thousands
across multiple clusters in multiple
continents
here you can see the number of servers
that we want the number which we are
booting up
and the number which are ready the
allocated column would update once
players start connecting to them
rob you asked about scaling up enough
resources for a
million concurrent players deploying
thousands of these servers across
10 000 cpu optimized cores ought to do
the trick
let's check those gke clusters remember
we only had one node in each zone
let's see what it's up to now that the
cluster auto scaler has seen our request
spike
this is great the cluster auto scaler
has already begun adding additional
nodes to these clusters
based upon the resources that we've
requested
okay more and more game servers are
coming up agones and gke are working
together to spin up additional virtual
machines to handle this load
this will take just a couple of minutes
to scale up let's check back in on these
later
back to you rob thanks sub it'll be
interesting to watch that scale up
and while that's happening let's talk a
little bit about the components that are
required to power
a global game so first you need a global
network to connect with your players
next you need high performance compute
to run your simulations and your
multiplayer matches
then you need a global database instance
to track player progress
throughout the game you need to monetize
your game so you'll need
planet scale analytics that can absorb
all the events you're going to be
posting
and then finally you need a fleet
orchestrator to bring it all together
and to scale this infrastructure up as
players join your game
and to scale it down as players move on
to other activities
let's take a look at each one of these
components in more detail
let's start with our global network the
first thing that you'll notice
on this diagram is the 24 regions
distributed around the globe
these are represented as colored circles
and are the geographies where you can
run your compute resources to power your
matches
the next thing you'll notice is our 144
edge points of presence that are located
as close as possible to your players
now the unique and differentiated thing
on this diagram
is the fiber optic network that ties our
edge points of presence
and all of our regions together only
google cloud
offers a global private fiber optic
network
out of the box next let's talk about
compute
which you'll need to power your
multiplayer matches
so we know that there are many different
types of games from a casual mobile
title that you play on your phone with
friends
to a powerful and high fidelity
multiplayer battle royale match that you
play on your pc
or console at google cloud we've created
a spectrum of compute
that you can tailor to the specific
needs of your game
so for that casual title you can run on
our cost
optimized vms and for that high fidelity
battle royale title
you can run it on our compute optimized
vms which run at high clock speed and we
built specifically
to run demanding workloads like games
next let's talk about a scalable
database as players progress through
your game
you'll need a way to capture updates
like rankings and updates to inventory
the way that a database for a global
game is typically built
is by utilizing a commodity database
like mysql
and running tens or even hundreds of
instances
to power a global game this technique is
not globally scalable
and from an ops perspective is not
awesome at google
we offer an alternative approach with
spanner
a horizontally scalable relational
database
we offer the capability to run a single
instance
that can serve all of your players
globally without shards
now that's awesome so we've talked about
a lot of different infrastructure
components that'll be required to power
your global game
it's going to be important that you can
effectively monetize
particularly in today's free-to-play
world
bigquery offers a globally scalable data
warehouse
that can scale from launch to the
world's biggest games
with zero ops for your team candy crush
is probably the best example of scaling
running on bigquery
candy crush ingests over 70 billion
events per day
seamlessly and google manages all the
ops
so to tie it all together you'll need to
scale these resources
up and down throughout the day as
players join the game
and move on to other activities to
manage the scaling of all of these
resources deployed globally
we built google cloud game servers a
global control plane for running your
game
google cloud game servers is built on
top of open source
technology including agonise and
kubernetes
which allows you to run your
infrastructure components
wherever you need them in gcp on other
clouds or on bare metal
let's take a closer look
in this diagram we're showing the game
servers api
which is your global api and control
plane for managing your game
on the left we have one kubernetes
cluster that's running in google cloud
platform
on gke on the right hand of the diagram
we have another kubernetes cluster
that's running on premise
on bare metal both clusters are being
centrally managed by google cloud
game servers and all of the operational
events and log events are being captured
centrally agonase and gcgs
offer a new cloud-native way to build
your game
let's talk about the road map for
building your game with this new
technology
first you containerize your game and
implement the open source agonise sdk
next you register each of your clusters
with the game services
api control plane then you begin
organizing your clusters into groups by
geography that we call realms
next you define configs for things like
auto scaling policies
and finally you test and roll out your
game server binary
to your global fleet of game servers
running on kubernetes
so let's check in on our scaling seb how
do you think things are looking
pretty good from here let's take a look
okay rob let's take a look and see how
our servers are coming along
so far we've got 4 200 servers running
in the u.s
a little over 3 300 running in the eu
and 500 running in japan
this is truly a global fleet more than
enough to support
1 million concurrent players as each
server can handle at least 150
players it took under 8 minutes to scale
up all the compute needed for a massive
deployment
all around the world this really
demonstrates just how easy
and powerful managed to gones really is
now let's take a look at the database
here we can see the number of nodes
we're currently using
along with the cpu utilization and
number of concurrent requests
wow that's a lot of requests and this
number should keep rising as more and
more game servers come online
we're running about 80 000 queries per
second
which is about what you would see for a
very large global game
should we need to handle more rather
than deal with database sharding
we simply increase the node count in
spanner and it handles the rest
you gotta love the separation of compute
and storage
now let's check bigquery our gaming data
warehouse where we've been ingesting
massive quantities of telemetry events
since we started our fleet
so far this table is just about a
hundred gigabytes with over 800 million
rows
excellent but let's figure out the
number of events processed per second
even though there are thousands of game
servers inserting data right now
let's ask bigquery to take the number of
events between the last two minutes and
one minute
and then divide by 60.
what i love about this is we can keep
inserting more and more data and let our
scalable databases handle the rest
when your cloud can scale to ingest data
like this your team can focus more on
creating really great games
and less on managing your infrastructure
wow over 800 000 rows per second
not bad
so rob in less than 10 minutes we scaled
up close to 10
000 cores of compute on three continents
wrote over 80 000 inserts per second to
a global database instance
and ingested over 800 million rows to
our data warehouse
talk about scalability wow
those are some impressive numbers sub we
were able to scale
all of the infrastructure required for a
million concurrent players
in about 10 minutes to recap
let's take a look at each component in
this toolbox
for building massive global games on
google cloud
our premium network offers a global
fiber optic network
extends your reach to wherever your
players are around the globe
compute optimized vms offer the high
clock speeds required for today's most
demanding games
spanner provides a global database
instance for your game with no
sharding bigquery
is a planet scale data warehouse that
can ingest
millions or billions of events each day
for your game
and finally google cloud game servers
the fleet orchestrator that can scale
these resources
up and down seamlessly during the day as
your players need them
to learn more join us on the web and
we'd like to thank you
for joining us today so seb that was a
pretty cool demo
we were able to scale up a million
concurrent player fleet
in about 10 minutes so for our viewers
what would it take to scale up a fleet
for 10 million concurrent players
well because the infrastructure and
technology are sort of taken care of for
you
the only thing that i could think of
would be more quota
you